revisamos los titulares de la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de un
rosa bienvenida a la religión es para ti
muy buen día vamos a empezar hablando
con una noticia que ocurrió el sábado en
colombia y fue la captura de alias
otoniel del clan del golfo vamos a ver
13 periódicos tres medios de
comunicación mejor dicho colombianos y
empezamos con el espectador rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente nos hemos querido
fijar en como la prensa colombiana sigue
abriendo no con este tema del que se
hizo repercusión a la prensa también a
nivel internacional si te parece
empezamos con el espectador así es y
titula el expediente otoniel el hombre
más buscado de colombia este artículo lo
hizo jordan rodríguez
exacto este artículo lo que hace es
repasar no la trayectoria de darío
antonio úsuga más conocido por todo el
mundo como otoniel y ya pues se explica
este medio que empezó involucrándose con
grupos sobre todo paramilitares desde
los 16 años hasta que pues en 2007 acabó
formando este grupo ilegal vinculado con
el narcotráfico conocido como el clan
del golfo por otro lado también señala
que las autoridades colombianas
recordemos le atribuyen la mitad de la
droga que sale de colombia y alianzas
internacionales por ejemplo con el
cártel de sinaloa por otro lado también
señala que fue recordemos santos el ex
presidente colombiano quien lanzó por
primera vez esta macrooperación contra
él y su grupo y también fue santos a
quien le negó cualquier tipo de acuerdo
con la justicia por otro lado este
artículo también señala pues que se le
atribuyen cargos por múltiples delitos
sobre todo por narcotráfico pero también
por homicidio terrorismo o delitos
sexuales y que también tres tribunales
de eeuu pues piden a su extradición lo
que ya han confirmado las autoridades
colombianas y que ahí el territorio
estadounidense podría llegar a cumplir
cadena perpetua rosa vamos ahora con el
tiempo alto soy otoniel no me maten los
detalles inéditos de su captura exacto
el tiempo cuenta con una fuente anónima
que el propio periódico identifica como
un investigador de la policía nacional
colombiana y quién es pues declara
explica este momento lo que habría dicho
o tenían en el momento de su captura
cuando un miembro de las fuerzas armadas
colombianas lo estaría apuntando con un
fusil y entre otros detalles quedan de
su captura de cómo se desarrolló esta
operación es que por ejemplo otoniel era
diabético y esto lo obligaba a instalar
camas ortopédicas pues en sus distintos
habitáculos y que esto fue clave para
las autoridades para pues identificar su
presencia que por otro lado también
observaron distintas personas que
estarían llevando comida ahí donde pues
las autoridades sospechaban que estaría
escondiéndose pues comida que se
correspondería no con esta dieta
diabética por otro lado el investigador
también señala que el punto crucial de
su detención dice las fuerzas militares
la policía lograron sacar a otoniel de
su zona de confort el nudo del paramillo
y obligarlo a desplazarse hasta hacia el
urabá antioqueño y que allí hace dos
semanas se consolidó el área donde se le
podía encontrar así el rosa vamos ahora
con semana una entrevista al sacerdote
jorge o
desde el urabá donde fue encontrado
otoniel titula otoniel se veían las
fotos como si estuviera preparado para
su captura rosada más esto lo ha
comentado muchísima gente en las redes
sociales exacto pues nos hemos fijado en
esta entrevista de semana porque
precisamente no el sacerdote de urabá
comenta un poco a este medio colombiano
qué es lo que está sintiendo la gente en
la región en este que era el bastión del
clan del golfo y por otro lado por un
lado pone en cuestión pues las palabras
de duque no porque duque señaló que este
era el fin del clan del golfo pues este
sacerdote dice que lo duda que
seguramente va a ver hay un relieve y
por otro lado también comenta que los
residentes de la zona tienen miedo a
posibles represalias y a que aumente
todavía más la violencia en la región
rosa y con una organización criminal tan
grande pues no es fácil no que se acabe
solamente con la captura de su cabecilla
continuamos con otra noticia vamos a
españa el diario punto es el futuro de
juan carlos primero incomoda al gobierno
porque rosa pues porque se cumple más de
un año desde que el rey emérito juan
carlos primero saliera del país hacia
los emiratos árabes y dos y ahora pues
se está planteando ya desde hace tiempo
insiste en eso pero se está planteando
regresar a territorio español y lo que
plantea este medio pues de españa es que
tan incómoda como fue a su marcha del
país pues sería su potencial regreso que
por un lado la fiscalía española está a
punto de cerrar las diligencias que
abrió contra el ex monarca y que pues al
cierre de estas investigaciones podría
ser que juan carlos regresar al país
pero que sin dar explicaciones sobre
todas estas acusaciones de supuesta
corrupción que se le atribuyen pues que
esta vuelta al país wood podría volver a
manchar la figura de su hijo felipe
sexto el actual rey de españa muy
rápidamente situación de el coronavirus
en rusia con el monstruo time y rosa
exacto hemos ha querido fijarnos un
momentito en la situación en este país y
es que se registraron hoy 337 1930
nuevos contagios de coronavirus lo que
es un nuevo récord para para el país y
mil 69 muertes fallecimientos no por lo
tanto el presidente vladimir putin ha
vuelto a pedir a los gobernadores
regionales que implantarán nuevas
medidas como es el cierre de la
hostelería entre 11 de la noche y 6 de
la mañana y también que la gente se
vacuna porque eso es una de las
problemáticas rosas muchísimas gracias
vamos ahora con nuestro primer invitado
el día
[Música]